I make the full-scale model on the 4x4
cedar beans and each 4x4 that gets cut
influences the following one and so on
so in some way
the building of this is just a reaction
to what's already there
what happens with a piece this size is
that I only have a 16 foot ceiling so I
was only able to build up to about 13
feet and then I had to take take that
off leaving a chunk of it on the floor
and then building on top of that very
hard because I always have to be aware
of what's all around me you're looking
on the side of it so that's a whole
different way of working
this is the pattern that gets thrown on
the plastic and then placed
but Colorado that crucible and what
we're after is this surface recording
accurately in hello that's the art after
the bronze its
officer I'm very
absolutely the longest piece of lace
I've ever done you know with really kind
of ballsy opening one being different
from every other
I think the patina gets Lauren or never
we've been at this where I guess four
whole days so far we have like four
three people on George's probably take
another
two circles and put them around a
something that rotates very heavily and
then rub them on the surfaces that come
out and when I do that I keep thinking
that I want to pretend that I'm the wind
I think it will be perceived I mean it's
something truly majestic and magnificent
and I think I want to make sure that
everybody understands sort of what the
underlying aspects were not just the
creativity the the process that was
involved to to you know to actually
create the finished sculpture
you good
come down the walk they all have to go
in not just right there kind of push it
around wiggle it shake it fry it until
we can get all of you started from there
you can use a wrench
I think it has such brilliance such
majestic presence that I think people
will see it as something absolutely
wonderful and I think it will be one of
the go-to sculptures you know in a
beautiful lace area on top will be lit
up from inside so that if you walk by it
will remind you of little synapses in
the brain and then it will be lit up you
know from the ground so it will stand
they just is a monument to art a
monument to science sure it's just the
kind of drama that I want and actually
so do the surfaces and I also think it
has the
that's flowing from
okay
I feel proud to have one of my pieces in
front of a place that also works on
helping humanity on making discoveries
that help with unearthing things that we
need to know
you